good morning Hank it's Tuesday as you
can see I'm in the middle of a small
office reorganization project which has
gotten just a little bit out of control
so in the process of my office
reorganization project I've come across
a lot of great things like this beanie
which I'll be wearing for the rest of
the video Hank I've also come across
this notebook which I apparently filled
with journal entries when I was in
Middle School during the first Gulf War
even though I don't remember ever having
written any of this in total I wrote
about 200 pages in this notebook and you
my beloved brother are mentioned zero
times but don't feel bad Hank there's
nothing about mom or dad or our
grandparents it's all about me Hank let
me give you a little example of what I'm
talking about hi how's it going my life
is good the ground war could start any
day now
I still like Whitney I'm pretty sure
that this 200 page study in narcissism
was an assignment for a composition
class so it's mostly just like song
lyrics that I write down to try to fill
up space for example and I swear to God
I am not making this up I heard a new
song on the radio stop collaborate and
listen ice is back with his brand new
invention and then I go on and I quote a
lot of ice ice baby and then I say I
like rap I like black nationalist rap
here's another charming doozy life sucks
I was doing fine until James and Brian
came along and they told Jennifer I said
I was going out with her which I did say
but they shouldn't have told her and
then when I'd read almost the entire
journal I came across this page where I
say maybe someday I'll be reading this
so from now on I have to be truthful I
haven't lied that much in this journal
so now I am forced to read a document
that I don't remember writing under the
assumption that much of what is
contained inside its pages is untrue
frankly I hope that I made it all up in
some kind of fever dream but by far the
most interesting thing about this
document is the way I write about
Whitney whom I apparently loved
immensely even though until recently I
had forgotten her last name there is one
moment here where I literally say I
don't know why I like Whitney she's so
flat oh my god did I really say that
and
and I think that it was an acceptable
thing to write down and then to keep for
many years so girls let that be a lesson
to you you need to know that boys are
more like that than they are like Edward
Cullen and boys when you like a girl be
nice to her
not like drive faster house in the
middle of the night nice just nice also
if you are an 8th grader or if you have
an 8th grader take heart it's probably
not this bad and I turned out alright I
mean I'm a grown man wearing a beanie
making videos on the Internet tank I'll
see you tomorrow sorry I didn't mention
you in my journal I feel like crap about
it